this small town in the rift valley with
its breathtaking scenery and high
altitude is a renowned Athletics hub
here you'll find athletes known for
middle and long distance running
many have worn numerous words and gold
medals yet as the runners continue to
break records dozens of them are being
suspended from competition because of
doping
Kenyan Mark kangogo was a rising star
until recently
he competed in the mountains of
Switzerland and won one of this season's
toughest Trail events his tests showed
the presence of two prohibited
substances in his system he was banned
for three years and stripped off his
title so
I did not know those pills will bring me
stress I use them to deal with a knee
injury
I admitted to taking the drugs
unknowingly
Kenya has been dealing with the rising
use of performance enhancing drugs for
years as of the end of November 55
Kenyan athletes were banned and eight
provisionally suspended according to the
Athletics Integrity unit recently World
Athletics president Sebastian Cove
praised Kenya's efforts to tackle the
problem government has already committed
5 million dollars a year
for the next five years
that is 25 million US dollars
and that money will support that all-out
war against doping
Wilson Gibson a former World Marathon
record holder is finishing his four-year
ban after he missed mandatory doping
tests he says he's helping to educate
other athletes about the problem you
have to be very strict on what goes into
your mouth
that anything that goes into a mode it's
the responsibility of the adult
so there's that kind of ignorance for
adelites one of the most misused drugs
is prescribed for anemic patients it's a
job that increases the number of red
blood cells which carry oxygen to the
muscles drugs like this one are easily
available in chemists here all you need
is cash and a good pharmacist people
we've talked to say it's a lucrative
business some of the athletes like
kangogo who are under suspension say
they just want to keep their heads low
continue training wait out their ban and
hope they can compete again
Catherine soy Al Jazeera in The Rift
Valley